let's bring him Jim actually should we
he's just sat down here he is hi it's
good to see how are you thanks for
joining us
um the um former ambassador to Japan is
that where you were in the last hour and
he was saying um it was talking
obviously about the Prime Minister being
in Japan and he was making the point
that uh brexit has had an impact uh and
now it's basically two sensors that's
they're still having a presence in the
UK but a bigger presence in Europe what
would labor do about that sort of
problem
well to some degree it's a natural
consequence of leaving the single Market
which means that all the trading
partners do need to trade with two
separate markets uh that's never what we
can do though is to remove barriers to
trade so it's obviously good news uh the
prime ministers uh in Japan but the
reality is that our exports have dropped
to an all-time low the lowest interest
cards began we need to far more to
rebuild that International standing to
make sure that jobs here in the UK are
supported
do you agree with Nigel farage never
thought I'd say that in a sentence that
brexit has failed well certainly a lot
to answer for I think the question is
you know once a British people made the
decision to leave uh the EU it was for
the government the Tory government to
make sure that brexit could be made to
work and they haven't done that I think
the way that they've been sold uh kind
of embroiled in their own internal
rounds in the way that we see on many
other issues has meant Britain hasn't
made the progress that it should have
made so we've been very clear that we
respect the result of our friend and we
want to make uh brexit work for working
people and what is it that the Boston
was actually saying yesterday because
obviously it's in a lot of the papers
this morning basically depending on
which side of the argument you're on
um he he wants to more or less rip up
brexit and start again well I mean he
certainly hasn't said that uh he'd been
very clear that the agreement is a
framework and it's a starting point but
it's not the end because there are
naturally gaps that we need to fill if I
give you one example in my own area
veteran agreements you know the reason
why uh farmers in Northern Ireland
struggle to trade with Great Britain is
because the veteran agreement isn't in
place and that's the same reason by the
way the farmers in Great Britain can't
trade with our European Partners either
a veteran agreement in place would
reduce red tape and allow us to trade on
a competitive basis that's just one
example of where we can fill the gaps
and the rules about our security on
Science and Technology where we just
need to work in cooperation and
partnership about free movement of
people well Keith has been very clear
that that isn't on the table that's not
something that we're going to return to
and in the end what we need to do is
almost to take the politics out of it as
much as we can do I understand this is
quite a charge debate we'll just say
what does the economy need how do we
build a Britain that can thrive in the
future where we go away from that 13
years of decline in depression to a
point where people can be hopeful and
optimistic for the future and that
requires a strong foundation and for us
to respond to what businesses are saying
and they're saying that they want the
barriers to trade reduced and they want
simplicitor for that red tape to be
taken away one of your colleagues
Matthew pennicott was sat where you are
yesterday and we're talking about
housing and so I think everybody agrees
that we need more housing bills the
housing stock is not good enough in the
UK at the moment and I was asking him
how many houses a year you would commit
to even when you are in power he
wouldn't give me a figure
what's your figure well at the moment
it's very difficult to do that because
the way uh that we believe that ultimate
on is from the Grassroots up uh you know
communities not their area far more than
anybody else they know the infill size
that can be developed they also know the
local housing demand uh the worst type
of any uh politics is when you impose it
from the top in a way that bears no
relationship to the reality on the
ground but we do recognize that there
will be degrees of tension within that
and so how communities are supported to
develop those housing numbers that will
be required and I would say that most
people recognize that we have a housing
shortage they have their children their
grandchildren that can't get on the
housing ladder and they want them to
stay in the community where they've been
born and raised well for that to happen
we need housing for them to live in so I
think the community will be on board
provide them that we do it from the
graph for result so have you not started
that piece of work have you not been
asking local communities well many local
areas have a local planning place
already with the housing targets already
in place from the current government of
those numbers but what we're saying is
that we need a new approach and that new
approach is to develop it from the
ground up and also to have a different
approach to how we prioritize land you
know I you know a town like Oldham have
a lot of post-industrial sites or
Brownfield sites that are dirty
contaminated that we need to bring back
to the market so that people build on
the Brownfield size and not the green
belt first well that can be done as we
know we saw that done in Liverpool it
can be done but it requires an active
government that uses the leave as a
government to make it happen and what I
found over the last 13 years is that
those Urban real programs that were live
when labor was last in power have been
taken away incrementally to the point
now where we see his stagnation your
size that should be developed aren't
being developed people wait in the
housing waiting list people desperate to
get unhousing ladder and they're not
able to and it's a crime so you won't
give me a figure but will you tell me
are you going to build on Greenbelt uh
well that's going to be about how we
work with local communities to find the
land that's appropriate we recognize by
the way the importance
the green belt is very important and
it's important for a number of reasons
but it also have a very different
character in different places there's
many parts of England that you'll look
at the green and pleasant land and the
Roland Hills they're actually not green
belt at all but you would still want to
make sure that they are protected from
uh sprawling from development there are
others where they're actually a very
important buffer in between urban
developments that separates Town
developments and they're very important
for access to Nature and to give people
quality of life and so it's got to be
right for the local circumstance which
is why I say it's got to be built from
the ground up so you're ruling out
building on Greenbelt it's about how we
work with local communities to find the
right place for development to take
place but if you're saying that it's got
to be about how we work with communities
to make it happen and develop a plan
that's right for them you've got to
allow flexibility in that plan okay talk
to me about what's going on with um
dumping sewage into our waterways I mean
when people start to read about the sort
of stuff that's being carried out it's
it's
basically Criminal but it is Criminal
and it ought to be criminal uh actually
we announced a conference in September
that we would make a criminal offense uh
with tough sanctions in place for water
bosses who didn't comply with the law
the problem is that the conservative
Government after 13 years have legalized
the number that's taking place you know
dumping that used to be illegal is now
legalized and we won't see an end to
that we actually brought forward a bill
in Parliament to end the tourist Jewish
Candle by 20 footer and that would be
automatic fines mandatory monitoring and
a target of Legally binding Target to
end it by 20 footer and the tourists
voted that down and I think it's a
bizarre situation now where the water
companies are saying you know what hands
up we apologize for what's going on it
shouldn't have happened and we want to
put it right it's the first step it's
definitely not the end but where are the
government on this now the government
have levers the power where they could
Outlaw The Dumping that's taking place
today the second thing I would say was
who's going to pay the price you know
these water companies have taken 72
billion pounds of dividend payments out
and they should be made to put the
system right we can't allow in a cost of
living crisis for hard-working families
to face the burden of that because water
companies still thinking carry on
business as usual and taking billions of
pounds out every year and what do you
think on a personal level um Jim of
members of our royal family being chased
around New York in the dark
uh well I mean looking at the reports
that are coming out we clearly see how
they'll settle down there are fairly
different views about uh what exactly
happened what you have to say is a point
of principle is uh public figures should
be accountable and we should be open to
press scrutiny uh in the way you'd
expect but it's got to be done in a
respectful way and a safe way the other
thing to say on a human level is you
know for Harry himself you know we can't
take away his past and his personal
trauma on this and so you know what
might seem one experience on the
pavement watch observing it passing by
can be a very different experience if
you're the person in the car with
anxiety that almost certainly he felt